so as we continue with issue number two
of age of Ultron I think you guys are
actually going to find this story
extremely interesting and and well worth
our discussion because what this is
going to do is give us more of an idea
of what else going on here and this is
where I say this story was able to
capitalize on the Days of Future past
because again the Days of Future past
gave us a very very small glimpse into
what life was like in New York it was a
very small glimpse into what the future
was like but where Days of Future past
gave us this tiny window
age of Ultron gives us this massive
experience this massive up picture of
just how bad off the world is and what
we see as we start with issue number two
is that we're actually in San Francisco
rather than New York and we're picking
up with some woman as she's navigating
her way through what appears to be a
completely ravaged San Francisco and
again we see various bodies strewn
everywhere and it's really just kind of
goes to indicate to us that this city
has been absolutely destroyed but what
we also see is that there are all Tron
robots that are simply just traversing
through the city and again based on what
we saw with the events in New York the
Ultron robots seem to be just travelling
from one place to another attempting to
kill any sort of human life form that
they find and again this is tied in to
our discussion on Ultron and if you
haven't seen it of course I would
suggest that you guys go back and watch
it but with our discussion on Ultron we
had talked about how almost immediately
after Ultron was created that he
developed an insane hatred for not only
Hank Pym but for Humanity as well and so
it seems as though all these Ultron
robots exist to do is to traverse
whatever location Ultron has taken over
and to destroy any and all organic life
forms and with the actions of this woman
this is very interesting here what we
see is that she seems to have found a
location to hide at maybe hiding among
the dead which tells us that perhaps
these Ultron robots can't differentiate
between the humans who have been killed
and the humans who were alive or perhaps
she's buried herself so far under that
they're unable to penetrate the the dead
the dead humans in order to actually see
that she's alive but again once the
Ultron robots have passed she re-emerged
us from these corpses but almost
immediately after she does some
individual pulls a gun on her and so
what this man says is that he's she's
searching for something he
believes that she may have something
that she's got a car that she's got food
but whatever is that she has he demands
it and she turns around and asked him
where it is that he got this gun and
what we see taking place here is that
more or less this man while he initially
starts off confident with a gun pointed
at her that the longer this conversation
goes on the more shaken he becomes
indicating to us that this man's not
nearly as confident as he appears and
this seems to be something that this
woman is able to to pick up on she
points out that this man's a coward and
she reveals herself and what we see is
that this woman is actually black widow
natasha romanoff and that her face is
disfigured now most likely it's
disfigured due to the result of maybe
some kind of conflict with the Ultron
robots or the fact that maybe there was
a firefight we don't really know but all
we do know here and that her physical
appearance has changed and this man is a
little surprised by this he's a little
caught off guard by the fact that she's
facially that her face is disfigured and
so again as this man is trying to get
her to to hand over whatever is she has
this guy is in turn shot in the head and
initially natasha romanoff doesn't
really know what to do she's kind of
surprised by this but then we see that
she uses sign language to communicate
with somebody up on a roof now we don't
know exactly who this man is at first
but what we learned is that this is marc
spector
this is moon night and so what we learn
is that for the most part it seems as
though moon night and natasha romanoff
have formed this kind of alliance where
the two of them are trying to work
together to figure out what it is is
going on or the very least to simply
just stay alive and at this point
Natasha Romanov does really the only
thing she can which is to loot the
corpse of this man to take what he has
and to move forward Natasha Romanov and
marc spector agree to meet at a safe
house and again we're not exactly sure
what the safe house is but I would go as
far as to suspect that it's one of Nick
Fury safe houses but as natasha romanoff
is making her way we see that one of the
Ultron robots is in an alleyway and
appears to be telling some individuals
to to either submit or to perish and
these individuals run for they
immediately try to bail out but as soon
as they do they're all totally
incinerated they're immediately killed
off now natasha romanoff is able to stay
hidden she's able to stay away from this
and allow this event to take place and
it does seem I guess a little cold and
calculating it really is the only way
for her to stay alive and again this
point to just how dire the situation is
that almost immediately after any human
is spotted they're killed off why these
Ultron robots from here we pick up with
natasha romanoff as she enters some kind
of a barber shop and again this is very
I guess reminiscent of the early days in
Captain America comics when he and the
Falcon had transitioned to the basement
of a barber shop when we were at when we
had our discussion during the Infinity
Gauntlet about quasar about Wendell
Vaughn and again it seems as though
they're descending down into a safehouse
into someplace that's very well hidden
and March Spectre is meeting her there
and Mark Specter tells her for the most
part that this situation that they're in
this place at the rim is more or less
the safest place for them to be at
there's really the safest location they
can get that every day things are
getting worse and worse that more and
more people are got are dying and so we
see that this this sort of wall has been
created where we see various superheroes
who have been pinned here now we don't
know exactly whether or not all these
individuals are dead or if all these
individuals are alive or if maybe some
of them are dead and some of them are
alive we're not a hundred percent sure
there are some people here that we would
think wouldn't be affected by this for
example the Silver Surfer we would think
that this is largely an Earthbound event
and the Silver Surfer is largely in a
beyond the earth kind of character where
he simply only gets involved on the
planet Earth if there's some major sort
of crisis going on here but we also see
people like the wasp Luke Cage who we
know is alive the century Robert
Reynolds Black Bolt and so for the most
part we're led to believe that maybe
these individuals are alive but again
this is just kind of of up for debate
here what we also learn is that this is
indeed nick fury's or one of Nick Fury
secret hideouts and that while Nick Fury
has a large majority of them all around
in different locations that again this
is probably one that most people don't
know about and the reason why Natasha
Romanoff tells us this is the case is
because Nick Fury never kept things any
ever never kept them written down he
never actually left a paper trail for
anybody to follow and so because of that
no one knows about this safe house
except for those individuals that Nick
Fury may have told or those individuals
who for whatever reason it's simply just
stumbled upon it now whether or not it's
possible that Ultron could find this
place by interrogating other people who
may have known where it is is something
we don't know but I would go as far as
to say that I doubt the Ultron robots
would go as far as to interrogate
somebody and then track down to humans
when it's inevitable that they would
most likely die out of starvation or
dehydration eventually due to a lack of
resources as time goes on but from here
we transition back to a Central Park
back to Peter Parker and what we get
with Peter Parker is actually a really
cool story here Peter Parker more or
less gives us this idea of what's going
on from his perspective in the sense
that we learn how everything began to
unfold here and what Peter Parker tells
us is that this all started while he was
asleep that he was simply just in his
apartment presumably the night after
Heuer gets the day after he had spent
all night long parading around as
spider-man and fighting various
criminals here and there but what wakes
him up is this kind of explosion this
massive shift and when he looks out the
window he realizes that some giant
machine is tearing through New York and
as things progress as panic begins to
rain that he's trying to figure out what
it is that's going on now for the most
part this is about as in-depth as our
story with Peter Parker goes in this
comic but what Peter Parker also tells
us is that this seems to be everywhere
that there is no safe place there is no
military there's no Washington DC that
everything is gone here the other
question that he answers is the question
that everybody's asking of how it was
that he was kidnapped and why he was
kidnapped and Peter Parker says he
doesn't know he says that for the most
part all he knows is that as he was
trying to figure out what was going on
as he was trying to save various people
that his spider sense didn't even go off
that some kind of a flashbang initiated
and he woke up tied up to a chair but
what he also tells us is that he had
heard some of the guards talking some of
the people holding on to him or what it
was that they were saying and they were
saying things like they had struck a
deal with Ultron that they were going to
take people into Ultron and Ultron would
in turn leave them alone now of course
the question that everybody asks is
why would why would I'll try and do this
why would all Tron care about what it is
is going on with various people or even
if you did have a desire to eradicate
humanity why is it that he would work
with people why wouldn't he simply just
eradicate them on site and and
spider-man says that he doesn't know he
has no real idea what it is it's taking
place here he has no real idea why it is
that Ultron would get involved with
human with humans if what he wanted to
do was kill humans in the first place
and so from here we see this kind of
speculation taking place where various
people are trying to figure out what's
going on where various people are trying
to discuss what it is it might take
place but what we also see spider-man
saying is I guess asking is what it is
that they're going to do what the next
step is what what kind of planet is that
everybody has but what Tony Stark says
is that their only real plan is to
survive and Peter Parker says that
surviving isn't doing anything that they
have to do something and Captain America
agrees Captain America jumps up and says
that the reason why nothing had been
done was because they didn't have a plan
or at least not until now with that
being said we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end to hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace